sous les couleurs d'un ciel gris le
cortège de la gay pride
comme chaque année déambulaient cet
après midi dans paris avec pour
revendication lutter contre l'homophobie
parmi les manifestants et dans une
ambiance de carnaval
cette fois ci les politiques et n'ont
pas hésité à être en tête du défilé avec
notamment bertrand delanoë le candidat
socialiste à la mairie de paris
françoise valais mais diawara
l'extravagance est toujours là par
provocation ou simplement pour le
plaisir d'un jour 9 est une fête aux
couleurs guerre celle du drapeau arc en
ciel
si elle reste quelques unes la parade
est de plus en plus militante et doivent
en plus contribué à lutter contre
l'homophobie cch
je suis dans les établissements
scolaires ou l'orientation sexuelle
n'est pas abordée dans les manuels ni
dans aucune discussion
ensuite ça continue dans la rue avec des
insultes et des injures quotidienne les
choses sont en train de bouger mais il
faut continuer à occuper la rue et à le
dire au fil des années la gay pride a
changé la question n'est plus uniquement
de défendre la communauté
les revendications des homosexuels sont
maintenant reprise par les hétéros et
qu'elles sont légitimées par tout le
monde sait qui m'intéresse on l'a vu sur
le pacte mais on voit aussi
qu'aujourd'hui la différence sexuelle
est quand même et toujours un problème
pour pas mal de gens mais elle l'est
moins qu'avant et ce serait qu'on est
plus sur une histoire de l'égalité des
droits et ça m'intéressera sourit
aujourd'hui homosexuels des flots
sexuelle marchent ensemble au nom de la
tolérance et du respect de l'autre
gay pride c'est la fierté d'être soi le
sait l'estiment de soi un moment donné
c'est choisir de s'assumer tel qu'on est
c'est d'être soi même et ça veut dire
osé sortir du placard à aller dans la
rue et dirait bien que notre notre
identité et celle est différente des
autres mais qu'après tout sur le fond on
est une personne
la gay pride 2000 c'est ne plus être que
dans l'extravagance pour y glisser tout
comme la société le mouvement au
sexuelle est lagoon